we got a first look at PS 5 game boxes
half-life 3 could have been a rogue
light and Crash Bandicoot is on the run
on your phone I'm chasity and this is
your safe save for Thursday July 9th
[Music]
first up we got a first look at PS 5
game boxes and they're not that
different from PS 4 Sony revealed what a
PS 5 physical game box looks like by
showing off Spider Man Miles Morales so
it's a lot like the ps4 box except this
stripe is gonna be white and that 4 is
gonna be a 5 PS 5 has no set launch date
or price yet but there's a standard and
an all-digital edition with no disk
drive so you won't have this spidey box
on your shelf if you buy the digital
version of the console spider and Miles
Morales has no date or price either but
it will be coming out during PS 5 launch
window half-life Alex got rave reviews
but did you know that half life 3 was
nearly a procedurally generated rogue
light valve went through several
half-life 3 iterations since episode 2
in 2007 and one of them was a
procedurally generated roguelike game
Jeff gillies the final hours of
half-life Alex talks about this idea you
would explore randomly generated
buildings fight enemies inside and
rescue a prisoner story beats would
happen in between each building run but
the core principle of this was
replayability the idea was scrapped
because the procedural generation was a
problem for Valve's Source engine twos
lighting visibility and saving also a
proposed left 4 dead 3 was canned for
the same reason ultimately we did get
half-life Alex this year and the
decision to make it a VR exclusive was a
way for valve to try something new with
its game planning so reportedly Alex was
the sixth attempt at a half-life sequel
since episode 2 it took a while but it
might be the revival the series needed
what do you guys think it's a good time
for our favorite bandicoot not only are
we getting crashed for it's about time
but we're getting crash bandicoot on the
run on mobile it's a runner based on
Crash Bandicoot levels like temple ruins
turtle woods and Barrett there's a
crafting element where you build weapons
like rocket launchers to fight bosses
those bosses will be pulled from all the
crash games even The Forgotten ones like
the crash game on the tiger electronics
99x
you can play as both crash and cocoa and
both of them are customisable with
different skins Crash Bandicoot on the
run
to iOS and Android but there's no exact
date yet as a reminder GameSpot's Play
for all is still going on and even
though our final charity stream is
tomorrow we're still raising money in a
brand new way with GameSpot's store head
over to store gamespot.com to buy cool
Play for all merch for yourself
including face masks t-shirts hoodies
and this awesome skateboard all proceeds
go to charity until the end of August so
head to the store get something cool and
help us raise money for a good cause and
that's your safe stay for Thursday I'm
chastity you can find me on Twitter at
chastity underscore V Curt we'll be back
with more news on Monday see you next
time
[Music]